[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 10th of
february i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
after a bruising few weeks in
westminster and desperate to avoid a
vote of no confidence boris johnson has
been left behold into the demands of
tory mps
can the pm get out of his bunker i'll
speak to the spectators james forsyth
and katie balls
figures leaked to the spectator this
week show the nhs waiting list could
peak at 9 million in england and that's
the optimistic scenario but with
taxpayers already stumping up another 12
billion pounds for the health service
through a national insurance rise are we
really getting value for money
culture secretary nadine doris has vowed
to take action against companies like
netflix following a social media outrage
over a holocaust joke in jimmy carr's
new show broadcast on the streaming
giant douglas murray says the government
is overstepping the mark he'll be on the
show
kirsty allsop was ridiculed for saying
that if young people want to buy a house
they should give up luxuries like gym
memberships and holidays abroad and just
move somewhere cheaper does she have a
point
and finally what does the collapse of
the soviet union tell us about russia
today two experts will join me to
discuss
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord genuity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes canaccord are experienced
wealth planners and investment managers
who go above and beyond to offer you
support and guidance just visit
candywealth.com to find out more
and remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red button at the
bottom of this video and tap the bell
icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
and now on to the show
boris johnson's premiership is teetering
desperate to avoid hitting the 54-letter
threshold that would trigger a
confidence vote in his leadership he is
hunkering down appealing tory mps to
keep him in the job and making promises
to keep those mps happy in this week's
cover piece james forsyth looks at
boris's bunker the prime minister's new
defensive strategy to keep himself in
number 10. james joins me now alongside
katie balls
james in your cover piece this week you
take us into the depths of boris's
bunker dare i ask what we find there
so i think that borison's aim right now
is to placate his mps um as the old yes
prime minister joke has it you know the
public convert against you until the
next election your mps can vote against
you this evening or in boris johnson's
case write a letter against him that is
what they are most worried about because
if the 54 letters go in triggering no
confidence about that is a disaster for
boris johnson because
even if you win these votes as theresa
may will tell you
they end up wounding you it becomes a
it's a pyrrhic victory
and that you are essentially at that
point you know more than 100 of your
colleagues have voted said they have no
confidence in you and your premiership
begins to bleed out from that moment
forth so they are doing everything they
can to try and stop those 54 letters
going in so
things that tory mps want happen so
you've had this shake-up of the number
10 staffing operation this week you've
had a new chief whip and a new deputy
chief whip brought in this week um
things that are going to upset tory mps
like some aspects of boris johnson's
anti-obesity strategy are being dropped
despite you know him when he when he
first came up with these ideas you know
talking about how personally important
they were to him because
he because of how convinced he was that
his weight had contributed to how hard
he was hit
by covet so right now we are in a world
where boris johnson is doing everything
he can to try and keep his own mps on
board i think one of the problems is uh
something that casey discusses very
elegantly in her column
is that not all of his mps want the same
thing so you know take article 16 you
know there are people in the in the erg
parts of the party who want him to
trigger that very soon they argue that
if you don't do it soon
you know it would be a disaster to
trigger article 16 because it would
trigger a trade war of europe at
precisely the wrong moment in both
economic times and geostrategic terms so
i mean the difficulty is is trying to
please his mps but they don't all want
the same thing
and katie on to that column it feels
like a weekly if not daily battle for
the prime minister to keep these letters
at bay
you write in this week's magazine about
the caucus and the tory party that could
make or break his premiership
so i think there's various caucuses that
will affect boris johnson in different
ways and they're almost an endless
number now of tory groups so i begin in
my economy talking about the one nation
group of tories that's around 40 strong
group but can go up and depending on how
much you how you judge how regularly
someone attends or joins in with these
calls and but then there's also you know
the common sense group there's a
european research group there's a covert
recovery group and and we can go on all
day but
what i say in the column is ultimately
the group i think is reading number 10
is one that could take the number of
letters over the threshold of 54 is the
one nation group this is a group that
ultimately um
have had little love for boris johnson
um often see boris johnson at
loggerheads of what they want to do i
think lots of people will say that one
nation tory it doesn't sound like
something you don't want to be um
but ultimately this group you were
trying to define them and tend to occupy
traditional tour receipts um some of
them in lib dem touring marginals um
this group were particularly incensed
when um foreign aid
with the foreign aid cut um they've also
during the eu referendum virtuals remain
and boris johnson i mean i chaired the
hustings for the one nation group with
boris johnson and appeared before them
and it was definitely viewed as one of
his toughest audience because it's
grouper harder for him to win around and
so when it comes to letters and i think
uh at the weekend when you had former
minister nick gibbs letter going lots of
cabinet ministers are venting you know
saying this is the one nation tories i
think what's interesting which points to
james's argument about how it's so hard
to keep everyone happy i think the one
nation group could if they wanted to
trigger a confidence vote in the next
you know few days weeks but what is
keeping some of the from doing that some
of them are who are being very critical
of the prime minister but have not yet
submitted a little letter is they're not
convinced that boris johnson would lose
that vote right now i think more people
from other parts of the party need to
turn before you get to that point and
katie what about some of those other
groups that could still cause boris
johnson a headache you mentioned in your
column the god squad for example
yes so i think the groups that are
currently seen as i wouldn't say beyond
the pale but the ones that you know
hardest to bring back in the biggest
problem in terms of letters are one
nation group and also um those religious
stories which summon you know boris
alice referred to as the god squad and
you've seen uh you know gary streeter
one member of this group a question he
put in a letter um last week and i think
the um the issue here um or what is
worrying though is trying to prop the
prime minister up as one put to me as
their concern this group might just take
the view that prime minister is not very
moral and and where do you go from there
and i think that you can see this week
in terms of the moves boris johnson is
doing um as james rockman's cover piece
but also in those um pps appointments
which is the you know the lowest rung of
the ladder in government that the prime
minister now has new pps's and they're
really coming from the right of the
party um james duddridge
uh you have joy morrissey and i think in
doing this um he's clearly decided that
his future
um is gonna be one through shoring up
support on the right
and james on that point we've seen
changes in downing street now there was
a big clear out of some of his top
advisors we've had a mini reshuffle is
this enough to convince mps that are
frustrated that the right changes have
been made so i think there is a kind of
broad inclination to give boris johnson
and this new set up a bit of time
because it also story mps gave him a bit
of time because lots of them still want
to wait for this police investigation to
finish and the sugray report to be
published
i i i think that you also see that boris
johnson is trying to say story mps you
know look
i get the big calls right i might not
have handled you know how downing street
operated during knock down right but you
know look at the fact we're ending all
the covered restrictions in england you
know an announcement he's brought
forward by a month you know he told tory
mps that uh before prime minister's
questions on wednesday but i think one
of the things that worries tory mps is
what will make this story go away um we
have had in the last week or so three
really big government announcements
but all of them have been stepped on by
this story or muddied by this story so
you had the leveling up white paper
remember that leveling up is meant to be
the defining mission of this government
that was overshadowed by the fact that
three letters went in that day uh then
you had
the government spending over nine
billion pounds to help people with their
energy bills you know a big intervention
in the cost of living debate uh and yet
that was overshadowed by the resonation
of minira merza over um boris johnson's
jimmy savellebob at kierstama
uh then you had yesterday on wednesday
you had the prime minister announcing
that you know all covered restrictions
would end and a month early
that was uh that was overshadowed by the
news so that the police were writing to
50 people about uh the the uh alleged
lockdown breaches in downing street and
i think what tory mps want is for this
story to go away and i think that the
but the kind of question is how do you
make it go away and i think this is this
is what is worrying them i i think there
is an inclination to give this new
dining street set up a bit of time but i
think that the biggest desire is you
know how do we make this story go away
and katie boris isn't in that bunker
alone his wife carrie johnson has been
getting more attention these past few
weeks in the media about the role that
she's been playing behind the scenes
yeah so there's a book coming out by
lord ashcroft that was serialized um
over the weekend in the mail on sunday
and there's been a big kickback from
numbertown against that book against the
claims in that book about which suggests
that carrie johnson has a huge influence
over the prime minister and ultimately
blames her from various things that have
gone wrong
um and you've seen um
cabinet ministers such as sagittar javid
say you know it's sexist um quasi quad
tag on sunday wouldn't say it was sexist
but did say um that it was interesting
that people going after you know a
younger um prime minister's partner than
previous ones
um i think that obviously the phil book
is not out yet
i think that we have seen in recent
weeks um questions over
the various flat parties the fact that
we now expect um
50 members of downing street to be
interviewed over partygate after the
suga's investigation was referred to the
police and the expectation is that will
include boris johnson and his wife
carrie so
i think it's undeniable that she is part
of the story also if you look at the
refurbishment the flat still lots of
questions about this but ultimately i
think what's going to decide boris
johnson's future isn't so much his
partner as um and i think this goes also
to you know bringing new people in you
borrow lots of people around him but i
think increasingly as we get you know
resets and you know and blame games it's
more mp's working out if actually boris
johnson is the problem because he is the
one obviously making the final decisions
on things
james even if boris johnson's defensive
strategy works for a while this doesn't
feel like a very sustainable way of
governing the nation
yeah look a government has to have
higher ambitions than just keeping its
own mps happy i think one of the things
that is contributing to the discontent
with boris johnson right now is a
feeling that the tories have won their
biggest majority since margaret thatcher
but but they're not doing very much with
that i think that that is that is one of
the big problems that the government has
that you know people question you know
what is going on and you look at your um
superb story this week kate about the
the nhs backlog people are saying well
hang on a second you know
what are we doing we we've increased
taxes with the air we're planning to
increase tax in april with the aim of
clearing that backlog yet all of a
sudden we've been told that this backlog
is going to be going up until march 2024
and um one tory minister told me on on
having on having heard that you know
they said look if the nhs waiting list
isn't going to start to go down even on
the government's targets by march 2024
you know that is the most worrying news
for the tory party regardless of who the
leader is because that that exposes them
to both the attack that you know you
can't trust through the nhs and also
where did the money from that tax rise
go what good did it do and so i think
this sense of drift is a problem for the
government because it is compounding
kind of people's worries
about uh about whether you know this 80
seat majority has is being swandered
katie how long can the prime minister
prioritize his mps over his voters
well the question is do they align and i
think the view of many mps is the
problem is boris ross has been
prioritizing his advisers his aides in
number 10 over what they have been
saying and they think they reflect their
constituents more so if you think about
national insurance lots of tory mps the
bulk could not stand that as a policy
um
clearly pressing on and but i think that
you know borrower shots is also facing
lots of resistance over things that such
as his plan for cycling and such you
know parts of the green agenda so
ultimately i don't think it's as simple
as
who is he listening to voters or mps i
think there's ultimately
a question going forward as to what is
the direction of boris johnson's
government and just as with the
electorate that mps want different
things for him and i think he is going
to have to start picking her course
james and katie thanks for joining me
figures leaked to the spectator this
week show that despite a 12 billion
pound cash injection more than 9 million
people could be on an nhs waiting list
by 2024.
what's gone so wrong i'm joined now by
chris hopson the ceo of nhs providers
chris thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
now this tuesday in the house of commons
the health secretary sachit javid laid
out his elective recovery plan and this
is supposedly the parameters for how and
in what time frame we're going to tackle
the nhs backlog that's been made
significantly worse by covet 19 and the
subsequent lockdowns
the waitlist was at a record high 4.4
million pre-pandemic it's now around 6
million and is estimated to skyrocket
further what do you make of all this
well it's a very important moment for
the nhs i mean everybody in the nhs
knows that it's uh it starts start in in
the right place for me which is with the
patients which is we know because of uh
covid but also yes you're right the uh
waiting lists were increasing before we
went into copied we do have far too many
patients who are having to wait too long
for treatment and we absolutely know
that that potentially has a really
serious impact there are people who are
living in pain there are people who um
if we can't treat them quick enough do
risk having their conditions worsen and
become permanently worse so there's a
real real understanding in the nhs that
we need to get through these backlogs
absolutely as quickly as possible we
also um have been waiting for this plan
we did a lot of work on it before
christmas it's now been finalized and is
ready to go and that it indicates to us
how the money is going to be spent but
it also um sets out very very clearly
some more detailed targets that we had
when the money was first announced about
exactly what people can expect for this
extra investment that the money is
putting and the government is putting in
some figures were held back though so
javid said in the house of commons that
by march 2024 that wait list would peak
and start to fall but he stressed that
in the meantime the waitlist was going
to rise and by how much has been that
question that nobody seems to want to
answer the spectator in the magazine
this week does start to try to answer
that question revealing classified nhs
modeling
used to come up with that date and it
shows a peak of 9.2 million on the nhs
waiting list by march 2024 and that's in
the optimistic scenario that's expected
or forecast to fall to 8.5 million by
march 2025 so that would be a new
national insurance levy billions more
for the nhs to take us to a wait list in
three years time that's actually 2
million higher than where we are now is
that really good value for money
well i i think if you don't mind i'll
challenge the word nobody wants to
answer what the waiting list might look
like the reason we can't answer what the
size of the waiting list looks like is
because it depends upon the number of
people who didn't come forward for
treatment during covid how many of those
actually come forward and
i i've been tweeting over the last
couple of days to say one of the
problems the nhs faces is that we can be
hopefully relatively clear about the
volume of activity we can get through
which is why when the money was first
announced we made a very stretching
commitment that we would have around 130
percent of activity compared to
pre-covered levels would be delivered by
2425 but the bit that's really difficult
for us is being clear about how quickly
we can get through the waiting list
because we simply don't know how many
extra patients are going to come forward
and what we don't want to do is we don't
want to make commitments that we can't
deliver because then everybody will jump
on us and say hey look you promised you
would deliver this by a certain date and
you haven't and we also to be frank we
don't want to let patients down we want
to be very clear about what the
expectation for patients should be and
that when we make those commitments we
know we must deliver them because
otherwise patients are going to be led
down the garden path in a way that's
inappropriate so it's not because the
nhs is foot dragging it's not because
that we kind of don't want to make
commitments it's not because we don't
want to answer questions it's not
because there's private secret modeling
that we're not revealing it's basically
because this is a very uncertain
situation and we feel it's right to play
it fair for our patients play it fair
for our staff by only making commitments
that we know are deliverable they're
stretching ambitions that we've now
announced yesterday earlier on this week
but we know they're deliverable
so as you say nobody has a crystal ball
of course and forecasts aren't perfect
predictions when the information changes
you often have to change the forecast
and we don't know we don't know how many
people are going to be coming
forward and you also say you don't want
to
get expectations higher for patients who
of course been waiting a long time and
that's very understandable but the truth
is there are forecasts being done there
are nhs models that the nhs has access
to the department of health has access
to that we're deliberately not announced
by the nhs or by politicians uh because
that that data the the 9.2 million peak
the 8.5 million by 2025
it isn't pretty i can totally appreciate
not wanting to heighten expectations but
don't you think that we should level
with the public be honest with the
public especially as their tax money is
going up they're going to expect to get
better results and the very difficult
truth is that things are going to look
worse in three years time than they look
right now i mean don't you think the
public at least deserve to know that
well kate you can't say that things will
definitely look worse in three years
time because we absolutely don't know
the answer to that question what we can
absolutely say and of course you're
right this is a taxpayer-funded system
it is quite rightly led by politicians
who have to account in the house of
commons for how that money is spent and
of course all of our trust leaders are
absolutely focused on delivering value
for money because they know that this is
taxpayers money and that they should be
held accountable for how much they
deliver for that money and that's
precisely why we have made these much
more detailed commitments than were made
in the initial uh announcement where as
i said we committed to a level of
elective activity around 130 percent by
uh 24 25 while we've done more work to
try and give patients a clearer
indication uh in with a degree of
specificity for example uh breaking out
cancer about um when they can expect to
be treated because that that's part of
being held accountable i i just the bit
that if i'm honest kate i found
difficult about the article that you
wrote is the sort of implication that
sits behind it that somehow nhs trust
leaders are kind of seeking to evade
accountability they're seeking to hide
information they're seeking to
effectively as i said be dragged into
setting an ambitious uh target nothing
could be further from the truth every
single chief executive that i talk to is
really clear about the moral imperative
here about treating these uh backlogs as
quickly as they possibly can because day
in day out they are talking to patients
and they are seeing patients who are in
pain so they are going absolutely as
fast as they can and they're absolutely
making stretching as far stretching as
far as they can
to meet these targets but they also
quite rightly are saying they have to be
deliverable so i don't quite see this
picture of somehow a reluctant nhs being
dragged into making commitments when
actually it's those trust leaders who
want to make as stretching
commitments as possible because they
know the impact on patients if they
don't make those commitments well i
don't at all pretend to know it's in the
hearts of the nhs officials who are
negotiating this just looking at the
details of what was once thought to be
agreed at least on the political side
was that if you go back to summer 2021
there were
modeling there was modeling coming out
from the department of health showing
that hopefully by 2025 you would have a
wait list that was closer to 5.5 million
based on the tax rise the substantial
manifesto breaking tax rise that
politicians were considering and somehow
you get just a few months down the road
and that's gone up by millions and the
situation three years time is forecast
to look a lot worse than it does now and
i know that that information wasn't
wanted in the public domain so again
it's very reasonable to say that you
know you think the nhs is doing its best
it's reasonable to say that we don't
want to make promises we're not sure we
can keep but this elective recovery plan
has been based off these models based
off this time frame which has not been
published and again as you point out for
the patients who are in pain who are
suffering many who are uh going to
really struggle until they get access to
some of the selective care that they
need
shouldn't they have a reasonable idea of
the time frame that the nhs is looking
at behind closed doors shouldn't that be
opened so that the patients themselves
at least know what the nhs in this
recovery plan is based off of their
assumptions at the moment even if those
assumptions change because of course
that can be updated
well again i'm afraid i don't quite
recognize the narrative here in terms of
um and i've spoken to the people who on
the nhs side have been doing the
detailed discussions and and where we
were was that exactly as you say last
at the point last september-ish whenever
the government made their announcement
around the extra money for the nhs we
did a lot of careful work to agree a
specific top level uh activity target
around 130 percent of pre-covered
elective activity the work that we've
then been doing since is exactly what
you just said we're keen to avoid which
is actually to how do you turn that into
some commitments for patients because we
know that patients aren't interested
about how much activity the nhs is
getting through what they want to know
is when are they going to get their
treatment and that's precisely why
earlier on this week we announced a set
of detailed and they are very stretching
they are challenging ambitions but the
crucial bit is we know that they're
deliverable and so i just don't
recognize and neither do the people
who've been working on this from the nhs
side recognize a narrative that says
that we've been trying to hide things
there have been kind of sort of secret
uh pieces of analysis done that haven't
been put in the public domain what we've
put in the public domain is rightly what
we should have done which is
stretching
deliverable ambitious but clear targets
about when people can expect to be
treated
well the forecasts are now in the public
domain you can read about them in the
spectator magazine this week and i
suppose the public can make up their
minds as to whether or not they thought
that should have been published along
with the uh recovery plan but let me ask
you are you confident now that the nhs
officials and the government departments
are broadly on the same page about the
metrics that need to be achieved over
the next few years when it comes to the
backlog and many of the other aspects
laid out in the recovery plan because i
know uh from your thread on twitter that
it's about achieving those metrics and
those targets that matters a lot to you
yes i mean so um that there was some
interesting kind of speculation earlier
on in the week as to why there was a
delay in the plan and i tweeted why i
thought there had been a delay in the
plan which is you know what happens when
you draw up a plan is right when you get
to the last moment you agree all the
final details and what had happened has
been that over the last two or three
weeks there's been a lot of hugely
important work being done in precisely
the areas we've been talking about which
is what level of metrics how many of
them uh time commitments but also levels
of commitment against particular metrics
in other words what percentage of for
example um cancer diagnosis would we get
within the done within the required
target that work was done at real pace
and it's been done really you know very
close to publication date what then
happens is quite rightly is there's then
a debate around uh whitehall and there's
an assurance exercise where effectively
everybody kind of needs to sign off and
where we've got to is an agreed position
between the department of health and
social care nhs england number 10 and
the treasury and yes of course you'd
expect there to be backwards and
forwards on that um because that's
that's the nature of the relationship
between um the nhs and centre of
government and it's not the nhs
controlling the rest of government again
as your article implied it's actually
a process of negotiation and agreement
between all of those different parties
and that's where we've got to and the
nhs is now very clear we've been pushed
hard as we should have been by
government we've pushed ourselves hard
for the reasons i've explained we do now
have an agreed set of metrics um that we
will all now uh be working incredibly
hard to deliver and that's the process
working as it should be and if i'm
honest part of the problem here is that
if you try and pick out individual
elements of the process and say hey look
at this potential scenario here's a
leaked document that basically says you
know some potential scenario planning
what you're not looking at is the whole
and i think it's perfectly reasonable
for everybody who's taken part in those
negotiations to basically say we've got
to the most stretching and deliverable
place that we could have got to given
the context and the nhs is now
absolutely committed to delivering those
targets and we're absolutely
if you look at all our frontline leaders
they are now ready to deliver what needs
to be done and that's how the process
should work
i think again looking in the round
looking at the fact that this isn't just
about tackling the backlog it's about
the tax rise to pay for tackling that
backlog it's about all the decisions
that have been made around covet and
delaying certain kinds of care
the forecast from which that whole plan
is going to be
jetted off from uh is one that
potentially is going to be of interest
to the public and again they can they
can check it out in the magazine uh this
week uh my last question to you chris
then is um if you do think that broadly
speaking now having sorted out the
technicalities that these government
departments number 10 and the nhs are
roughly on the same page do you think
the tax hike do you think the money
that's going to go to tackling the
backlog is going to be enough or are we
going to see conversations in the near
to medium future in which the nhs
suggests it needs more funds or do you
think this is now going to cover it
well i think it's very inappropriate
i've said this for two or three people
over the last few days it would be
completely inappropriate for me
as somebody representing frontline nhs
organizations to come on and say hey the
money we've been given is not enough
before we even arrive and we've even
started spending it the point i have
made though which i feels to me to be an
important one is if you look at the long
term projections here i'll give you one
example the health foundation a
completely independent uh health think
tank is saying that we need a million
more health and care staff by 20 30 31
in order to provide the same level of
care as we are currently receiving what
that basically means is we will need a
discussion about exactly over the longer
term mid to long term about what level
of funding the nhs needs to provide the
right level of care
in an environment where right the way
across the world and we're no i'm not
unusual about this the demand for care
is rising and this is one of the
challenges that being in a
taxpayer-funded system um brings there
are lots of huge advantages the equity
is really important the nhs is one of
the most efficient systems uh health
systems in the world and that regularly
comes out of the data that's produced
but the question we will need to ask
ourselves is given the rising demand for
care that every advanced western economy
is seeing we will need to have the
debate about longer term what funding
does the nhs need and our wider social
care system need in order to continue to
provide the right quality of care and to
be frank expectations of the quality of
care are arising
i do have to wonder if the forecast 8.5
million on the waitlist by 2025 will
agree that the system is completely
equitable but uh we'll have to leave it
there chris thanks for joining me
thank you very much indeed
from sagiva to zara sultana politicians
from the right and left have attacked
jimmy carr for a joke he made about the
holocaust in his latest comedy show
for context here's what he said
when people talk about the holocaust
they talk about the tragedy and horror
of six million jewish lives being lost
to the nazi war machine but they never
mentioned the thousands of gypsies that
were killed by the nazis no one ever
wants to talk about that because no one
ever wants to talk about the positives
[Applause]
in his column for the magazine this week
douglas murray says that while carr is
quote one of the comedians i dislike the
most and despite the joke being quote
cruel and unwitty government regulation
was set a dangerous precedent to explain
douglas joins me now
douglas in this week's magazine you
write about jimmy carr what do you make
from the fallout from his netflix
special
well there's several very interesting
things about it um
one of them
is that uh jimmy carr i'm not a fan of
his um i'm sort of standing up for his
right to make
jokes including
unpleasant jokes
but what i think is happening here is
first of all is what is known as context
collapse where an in-group's
conversation is discovered by an
out-group jimmy carr's audience know
exactly what they're getting uh when
they go to his shows it's one reason i
don't go to his shows i don't think you
like what he offers but uh his his
audience his fans know what they're
getting when they go to his shows or
when they click on his netflix special
um what's happened this past week has
been that an out group has discovered a
part of this material
one joke from his show his dark material
was excerpted sent around on twitter and
he was then subjected to the inevitable
uh five minutes of hate
uh which follows it's a very typical
story um and
i think that the most worrying bit of it
is actually not the public or
twittersphere reaction which is as
deranging and deranged as it always is
the most disturbing thing is that
government ministers once again have
felt that they need to intervene and say
what they think should be joked about
and what should not
yes so the culture secretary nadine
doris has said that the joke was
shocking and has suggested that the
government would be looking at ways to
sanction outlets like netflix if they
were to publish this sort of thing i
can't help but feel this is going to go
badly badly wrong
yeah
as ever with politicians you get this
horrible feeling like we've not
discussed free speech before
perhaps in britain we've discussed it
for centuries
and we know the parameters and we know
the problems and we know the risks and
we know the rewards um but yes the idea
that nadine doris feels compelled to
speak about this and of course she's
culture secretary she's actually
potentially got some sway on it sajid
javid once again strangely it's another
intervention from him in uh the free
speech issue has has also uh condemned
what does the health secretary have to
do with deciding what content netflix
should or shouldn't put out what jokes
people should or shouldn't say and then
you've got the the worst person of all
is totally uh unheard of previously snp
counsellor of course it's someone from
the snp who had less understanding of
freedom than perhaps anybody else in the
country uh but it's an snp councillor
who has called not just for the
prosecution of of jimmy carr for hate
speech but the prosecution of his
audience for laughing
i mean this is just
as i say maybe we can just you know
ignore it because it's an snp counsellor
but it's very worrying that anyone uh in
any position of power at all in this
country has such a lack of understanding
of basic freedoms that they think you
should be able to prosecute people for
being caught laughing at the wrong
material it's pathetic
well douglas to go back to jimmy carr
you write in your column that if you
find a joke distasteful if you find a
comedian distasteful there's a really
easy way of handling this and that's
just don't tune in don't watch them
do you think there's ever a time where a
joke can go too far in which just saying
i'm tuning out i'm not paying attention
isn't quite good enough
oh i think jokes go far too far all the
time
one of the points of comedy in the
society is to try to work out where
those points are
another point by the way of comedy is to
help us deal with very unpleasant and
ugly things about life you know the old
saying you know if you didn't
if you didn't laugh you'd cry
comes from a very basic recognition
about comedy which is that it helps us
through horrible ugly dark things now i
think some comedians are very very adept
at uh at uh finding their way through
that jimmy carter gave him credit i said
i'm not an admirer of his particular
given credit isn't bad at navigating
some of that there are much better
people ricky gervais for instance but i
mean the history of comedy
is of people trying to find their way
through the maze of of current taboos
and and and much more and so of course
people can go too far but the other
point about that is they can go too far
for certain audiences as i say again
it's about this ingrid out group thing
um
a particular audience knows what they're
going to get
and an outside audience may not be aware
of that at all this is happening not
just with comedy it's happening with
literature and much more but i think
that it's strange that in our era
comedians keep on uh
becoming the sort of brunt of these
strange stampedes it happened recently
with a far more talented comedian than
jimmy carr which is dave chappelle in
the states
and the reason why it's happening as i
say is because comedians are meant to
explore difficult material
douglas one really interesting part of
your column was where you talk about
ricky gervais and a joke that he has
made about anne frank and you say in the
column that you think he was just on the
right side of the line you think he just
got away with it but you also say that
you probably have to be jewish or making
a deeper point in order to make a joke
like that and i'm curious do you think
that that is the case when it comes to
humor for all forms of identity
yes i i think so i think that it's i
think that it's
a comedian has to earn the trust of his
audience to allow for them to allow him
or her to go to transgressive places now
the obvious thing is that is that an
audience is more likely to trust the
particular comedian that they're going
to go to those places and be
trustworthy as it were if that person
already is clearly not for instance
beating up on a particular minority for
the sake of them being a minority the
most obvious example is um there are
things that black comedians are able to
say which white comedians are not there
are things that jewish comedians are
able to say that non-jewish comedians
are not and and i i give this example in
the piece about you know as it were
jokes about the holocaust because there
are some jewish jokes about the
holocaust um
and it's a sort of sub genre and it's
and it's
it's a very very complex terrain but one
of the one of the things that that has
existed in in what jokes there are about
the holocaust is
um an attempt not just to deal with the
horror
but to but to say something about it i
give an example in the piece of a a joke
of um
two people two men
killed in the holocaust they're in
heaven they're talking uh they're
laughing about something that happened
in the camps
and they're laughing so much they
attract the attention of god who's
passing by and and god stops and he says
my children my children how can you
laugh at
such things
and one of them says to god uh
i guess you have to be there
now i mean that that that's that's a
joke with a heck of a punch
and uh it has a real
real point to it now i think again uh uh
um
if audiences have to feel a confidence
that the comedian is is doing something
that and and has their trust the example
i give for the ricky gervais
joke about anne frank which i i thought
as they say and the piece you just
quoted was was just about from the
borderline was i said i'm not quite sure
you've earned the right to do that in
other words i sort of think a long and
you know
a very elderly comedian preferably
jewish
could potentially get away with that
joke but you have sort of trust you have
to trust them now is it well i i trust
ricky gervais on that but but that that
trust element with the audience is
incredibly important but but this is
this is about the sort of finery of of
comedy and comedy techniques and
what i worry about is a much broader
thing which is comedians keep on getting
it at the moment because of their
they're at the forefront of some of the
free speech issues of our time and the
absolutely central issue of our time on
this is a deep misunderstanding or at
least uncertainty in our societies about
what is speech and what is action
and uh this this sort of condemnation of
jimmy carr for this this i think very
tasteless and unfunny joke
seems to me to be constantly not just by
the idiot at snp counsellor but by
others as well
confused with action you know these are
words they are it is a joke and you
either laugh or you don't it's not the
same as action and uh we've sort of told
ourselves in our age that speech and
action are so close to each other
that you have to you have to always
stand down on the speech otherwise
action will inevitably follow and i
don't think that is the case i think
it's very lazy and as i say uh toward
the end of the piece i think one of the
reasons why the sort of stamping on the
comedians is happening is because it it
is quite easy in the court to hang the
jester it's much easier than ruling land
justly or wisely and i think that our
ministers and even our councillors
should reflect on that and douglas
netflix so far have not taken down the
jimmy carr special in the age of
cancelled culture it feels like not
taking something down feels like a a bit
of a win for free speech but i'm curious
as to how this compares to spotify and
joe rogan while i have you here i'd love
to know what you think of what's been
happening to him and i know that you've
been on his show a few times
yeah i admire joe enormously he's a
seriously talented comedian and an
unbelievably talented podcaster um
i don't think people realize unless
they've seen it done badly
what did what it involved to be as good
a at what he does as joe is uh it's
quite amazing to have sort of multi-hour
conversations completely gripping uh he
he has he has trust of his audience and
again it comes back the same thing it's
an ingroup out group thing
joe rogan has a larger following than
any commercial television channel
and a lot of the old media have been
gunning for joe and they've been doing
it
through very typical means again
selecting certain things
uh that they believe are being said that
the people in the conversation know are
not being said so
the bbc and others this week just ran
the story claiming that joe rogan has
had to apologize for racist language in
the past they they imply that joe rogan
has been a racist in the past and has
been caught using racist language and
this isn't the case at all and all of
joe rogan's followers know that he's the
furthest person from being a racist you
could possibly be it's an absurd and
obscene accusation
but but the allegation is made because
on occasions in the past they found
times when he has used the n-word in the
context of quoting somebody using the
n-word and and now there is a total
prohibition on even quoting uh uh people
saying that
and uh and that that is quite different
from somebody throwing around racist
language and calling people you know
vile racist terms so so the old media
has tried to just to destroy this
absolute um um top figure in the new
media i think it won't work i think
spotify
absolutely right to stand beside him
should stand beside him and not just for
commercial reasons but for very obvious
uh strategic and moral ones because if
you allow the mob to take out somebody
as as important as as impressive as joe
rogan it'll take out absolutely
everybody next so um spotify should
absolutely stand uh behind him i'm glad
they have so far uh i hope that netflix
stand up for jimmy carter i hope that
everybody stands up for their mates i
hope that everyone stands up for the
right of people to make jokes and to
explore difficult things uh and
obviously this is partly as you know
kate an issue of self-interest as well
because after they after they've
got rid of all of the comedians they'll
be coming for the writers and
journalists and
you and i better watch our backs well
douglas i very much hope that everybody
reads your column this week in the
spectator magazine thanks for joining me
it's a great pleasure
at the weekend location location
location host kirsty alsop found herself
in trouble after suggesting that if
young people wanted to buy a house they
should just move somewhere cheaper
in a piece for coffee house this week
matthew lynn says that alsop has got it
all wrong he joins me now
matthew thank you for joining spectator
tv
so first can you update viewers on what
it is that kirsty allsop the presenter
of location location location has said
about the housing crisis
yeah she's i mean she's saying something
which i think actually people have said
before and it's probably been said by
you know people of people of virginia
generation around around around a dinner
party um you know she was making the
point obviously you know there's a lot
of discussion about how younger people
particularly people in their 20s early
30s really been struggling to get on the
property ladder and she was making the
argument that you know if they were just
a little bit extravagant if they cut
back on their netflix subscriptions and
their and their holidays and their gym
memberships and their pelotons and you
know all that kind of stuff uh cut back
a little bit on the avocado brunches um
then you know then then they might be
able to afford a house she was arguing
you know when she was when she was
getting first getting on the property
ladder um you know she walked to work
and she saved every penny she could uh
and that kind of got her started and you
know in fairness that kind of that stuff
hits a nerve i think particularly with
people uh i think kirstie's around 50 or
so don't exaggerate her age but i think
i did check it um
you know it probably does hit a nerf but
i'm not actually convinced that she was
right about that but she certainly
stirred things up and attracted a lot of
attention well you've written on coffee
house that it isn't so easy these days
as i simply cut out the brunch
yeah no i mean i think that's true i
mean i actually think it was kind you
know you sort of sympathize with it a
little bit and you know i'm in my 50s as
well so if you're that you know the the
people that they are kind of a bit
irritating um and that's even before we
get into their taste of music and they
possibly are a little bit more
extravagant uh than people were 20 or 30
years ago but i think she's missing the
bigger the bigger picture you know um
actually we you know the truth is you
know we do we do have problems in the
housing market in the uk quite severe
problems and there's really you know
there's actually two big issues which
he's just completely overlooking you
know one we have a very very
dysfunctional planning system and you
know people have talked about that as
best spectator and lots of the
mainstream media we haven't and we
haven't built enough houses for 20 or 30
years uh we had very very high levels of
immigration um certainly led up to
brexit but actually post brexit as well
we still have quite high levels we have
changing family composition you know
people think about that you know your
families um split up more divorce rates
have been higher so you know what used
to be one unit turns into two or three
units um and that again changes creates
housing demand we haven't been building
nearly because we've restricted
the amount of land that people can have
and the amount of development uh
that that's allowed we haven't been
building enough houses to keep up with
demand and you know that that was
probably true in the 1980s but as you
just you know when you start restricting
artificially restricting supply
um
you know it just gets worse and worse
with every decade that that comes along
so i mean that's you know that's one big
thing that's happened so houses that's
made houses more expensive and the other
thing we've done is you know we've
manipulated um we've manipulated the
financial markets we've had a decade of
qe uh we're probably heading into
another decade of it uh you know and
that's pushed up the prices of every
every form of asset is pushed on equity
prices has pushed up modern prices but
most of all it's pushed up it's pushed
up uh housing prices and we've had
acceleration rising prices so you stop
and look at the numbers you know when
when kirstie alsop was buying her first
property the average house uh cost five
times what she says was her then
starting salary eleven and a half
thousand uh and now
um it costs nine times the average
starting salary so there is just a big
difference you know and just cutting
back on your netflix description and
going to the gym a bit less and you know
cutting back on the avocados that you
know that's not going to find the extra
hundred grand that you need to get on
the bobbie ladder it's it's facetious
and tragically it seems like plans to
tackle our archaic planning system in
government um have been shelved
one thing that really riled people up
about allsop's article wasn't just the
dismissiveness of young people's
lifestyles but the fact that she says
that she got family help when she bought
her first home and articles like this
seem to surface every six months or so
somebody says you know here's how i
bought my home by age 24 28 30. why you
can do it too and what always comes out
in the article is certainly hard work
determination you know saving wherever
they can but very very often almost
every single time they either admit that
they were able to live rent free
in their parents home or that they got a
big payout from the bank of mom and dad
to help them get on the housing ladder
that doesn't sit well with people who
don't have those options
no i mean i think that i think that's
true i mean you know i you know if if
you're if your father was a baronet as
it as in cursed your son's case and
you've got help for your parents uh
together to get a start on the property
later you know i think the truth is you
should pipe down a little bit and um you
know it's not it's not a good look um
you know you should remember that and
you know people are still obviously
getting a lot of a lot of help from
their parents i mean most of most of the
20-somethings you probably buy their
first property in london or south east
or you know some of the big cities you
know like manchester or bristol or leeds
you know probably are getting help from
their grandparents or their parents so
but you know as you absolutely rightly
say you know not everyone's in that
position um and you know it should be
possible uh
for you know really what we should be
doing with the housing market is taking
a step back and thinking you know it
should be possible in a in a reasonably
prosperous country that has actually
plenty of land um certainly don't really
need it for farming because we could
import food from around the world you
know now spending that it should be it
should be possible for somebody with a
decent job on the average wage to buy
you know a reason a reasonably nice home
you know that that should be achievable
and actually you know you mentioned the
planning system unfortunately we talked
about it a bit and there's so much of
the stuff with its current government
you know they kind of talk about it a
little bit and they're sort of
they're in the same universe as the
right ideas they acknowledge the right
ideas but when it comes to actually
doing them they seem to back away and
get nervous so they've backed away from
planning reform which they talked a
little bit but they should you know they
should press on of it and look at how we
actually get the housing market in the
right place because as i said a moment
ago you know people shouldn't need help
from their parents somebody who's
earning the average wage um in most of
the country should be able to uh you
know bear to afford a decent home that's
another thing she said in her article
which kind of railed people up and and
again was wrong uh was that you know
they should look at other areas you know
if you can't afford a house in you know
london or you know the nicer bits of the
home counties or in central manchester
you know go to somewhere cheaper like
county dome you know bits of the south
the south west
and again that you know
it's kind of a glib thing to say it gets
it gets some attention on social media
but you know she's wrong we shouldn't be
doing that as a country because what we
really want people
we want the workers to go to where
they're the most productive i mean you
know you know the economics of this
stuff okay you know we don't
particularly want people whether whether
whether where they're growing companies
uh we want people to go to london we
want people to go to bristol we want
people to go to manchester that's where
the startups are that's where the tech
companies are you know that's where we
want the bright 25 year olds to be uh
you know joining those kind of companies
that's where they their productivity is
going to be uh highest where they're
going to contribute the most to the
future growth of the company but if they
can't afford anywhere to live
you know that's making it very difficult
and we you know we really shouldn't be
saying oh let's just send them off to
turo or something or let's send them to
the government if the government had its
way it would be sending businesses and
the startups out to various regions as
part of their leveling up agenda where
did we start where do we start
yeah well in that very very long paper
in that very very long paper i didn't
see much in the way of incentivizing
those businesses to actually head out to
the regions which is what they're going
to need to get them to do if they're
going to be successful um but let me ask
as well you write in your blog that
there's an image of young people as
being indulgent and ungrateful is there
a bit of a prejudice here do you think
and is that maybe one of the reasons
that policymakers don't take the housing
crisis as seriously as they should
because as you said if you're earning
the average salary you should be able to
get on the housing ladder i mean i think
people would just like to be able to
imagine a time where they think they
could get on the housing ladder maybe it
won't be tomorrow or in two years time
but they'd like to think that in five or
ten years time they could buy a home
there's so many people in the country
earning decent wages who still don't
think that they can
you know i think i think that's
absolutely right and i and i think it's
uh you know i think it's a big problem
and i mean you know you may you know you
may be honest i think there may be a
little you know there may be a little
bit of a prejudice in that because you
know people's
you know they sort of they sort of look
at the netflix descriptions and and the
gym memberships and you know the kind of
levels of eating out
um which possibly have made garnet so
maybe people of an older generation
think that people in their 20s have been
extravagant but you know i i just think
it's silly you know that's always going
to be the case you know i'm sure you
know i'm sure my grandmother thought i
was extravagant you know because i went
on i went on a holiday once a year you
know people didn't used to do that
everybody everybody always thinks that
that's just a natural thing and i'll
come back at this point that you're
absolutely right you know i think it's a
big big problem that you know so many
people have been cut out um
as the property market it's actually
it's actually very important uh you know
for a functioning economy and for a
functioning democracy that people have a
stake in the system and that they you
know that they feel that you know they
can aspire to something which should be
pretty normal um you know and should be
achievable within a within a prosperous
country
and if they feel shut out from that i
think you know i think it is a big
problem we should be doing more about it
matthew thanks for joining spectator tv
pleasure
the possibility of war between russia
and ukraine isn't going away but after
well over a month of tensions we don't
seem to be any clearer on whether putin
is really about to invade
could the collapse of the soviet union
teach us anything about russia's
intentions this week's magazine we have
a review of the long song of tchaikovsky
street written by peter waterdrinker
which is a first-hand account of the
soviet union's final years
professor mark galiotti is an expert in
modern russian history and he joins me
now alongside lsc's professor vladislav
ziebach author of collapse the fall of
the soviet union
mark vladislav thank you for joining me
this week
mark we have a review in the magazine of
peter waterdrinker's book the long song
of tchaikovsky street which follows the
end of the soviet union
what did you make of it
well i mean i really enjoyed it i think
i enjoyed it for several reasons
one is just simply it actually spoke to
my own experiences this was just the
same sort of time that i was just
beginning my academic career
i did my phd with a lot of in on country
research in the last three years of the
declining decaying collapsing soviet
union
so you know a lot of it in admittedly
much much less exciting way than peter
water drinkers experiences but a lot of
it you know spoke to the stuff that i
remembered but secondly i i very much
liked the way that it connected the
collapse of the soviet union with the
collapse of czarist russia and the
revolutions of 1917 in sometimes a
fairly savage way i wouldn't necessarily
agree with
the history of all of it
but the passionate way it interconnected
these notions of collapses revolutions
and countries devouring themselves
and yet still potentially bringing forth
hope that i thought was was very nicely
encapsulated by the book
so water drinker was in the soviet union
in the 1980s can you tell us a little
bit about what that experience might
have been like
oh boy well i mean the very very first
time i ever went to the soviet union was
actually in
1980 um time of the moscow olympics when
moscow was trying to sort of spruce
itself up but even then one could really
feel this was a country that was sort of
grinding to a collapse but doing so in
all the kind of frankly without making
it sound too orientalizing delightfully
quirky ways that russia often can
remember being sort of costed by a black
marketeer and a hotel lift and i was
thinking aye aye i've heard all about
this you know we wanted to buy my jeans
or whatever and in fact he signed it up
to me and said you have agatha christie
there was even actually a black market
for agatha christie novels if only i'd
known before i went
but then through the 1980s i mean you
really could feel that this was a
country that was grinding to a painful
halt particularly ironically enough once
gorbachev was in power
with his quixotic attempt to try and
actually bring some kind of reform to
the country which may well i mean indeed
was uh sort of driven by a desire to
save the system
and yet it was exactly what was needed
to to bring the whole thing down and
certainly by by the mid late 80s
that uh you know inability to be able to
find anything you really needed in the
shops unless you what you're really
after was the collected works of karl
marx
um that sense that everybody unless they
were actually pretty high up within the
system was having to play the black
market just for basic essentials i mean
these are all the kind of ways in which
again people wonder how come the
russians became such effective and
rapacious capitalists well the answer is
they always were but they were having to
do it you know off the books and so
forth but you really got to see the
field in the 80s and i think that again
is something that comes out in this very
kind of wild east sense
vladislav in your book collapse you
write about the fall of the soviet union
now what changed between the late 80s
when water drinker would have been
covering this and 91 when the block fell
well everything changed and i and i
lived there i had my family i had to
raise my little son and stood in line to
buy milk for him and had all kinds of uh
of course uh recipes how to put food on
on the table but i didn't belong to
those russians as mark said who were
ready for rapacious capitalism at all
you know and i think you know 90 percent
of people around me were not and they
were totally unprepared for this
rapaciousness that suddenly you know
disgorged itself like you know a in a
famous painting of vesuvius engulfing
engulfing pompeii and i think it we were
all covered by ash of this capitalism at
least it was a feeling of many many many
people around them i felt that they were
struggling when the system disappeared
when the old economy came to a grinding
halt you know we're not covering the
reasons for it there were reasons
of course
but most importantly the state
disappeared i think you know police
didn't do their job they just covered
crime uh you know the kgb that uh was
the last resort of the regime to deal
with uh criminal economic gangs mafias
also began to cover you know criminal
criminal cartels so people felt
completely defenseless completely
defensive and that sense of being uh
covered by the ash of vesuvia capitalist
vesuvius being robbed uh cynically by
one so-called democratic government and
uh you know being exposed to any thief
any crook anybody that was the feeling
that i carried with myself although at
that time i was really really privileged
i already had western fellowships and
stipends i sort of
shuttled back and forth and i was okay
but i felt that the country around me
was deeply humiliated
people often say that the the fall of
the soviet union was inevitable but you
disagree when do you think the bloc
became untenable
well i disagree on the basis of facts
because you know when you put all uh the
factors together that are listed in
serious literature
beginning with uh you know dysfunctional
economy
overburdened by by military expenditures
the falling oil prices i mean chernobyl
catastrophe what not you put it all
together and still don't see how this
economy could have collapsed so rapidly
and so quickly and then i realized
because when you know some economists
pointed me to some intricacies of soviet
finances soviet economy and as i
listened you know gorbachev acted in
in a really strange way he was like a
captain of titanic who uh directed his
ship against the iceberg to that so that
the iceberg would make more bridges into
this titanic again and again and again
and finally the titanic surely sank but
what surprised me even to the end of the
book the titanic of the soviet union had
enormous resilience
and many many people didn't expect it to
sink to capsize in such a quick way mark
how present is the fall of the soviet
union in the minds of russian leaders
and in putin's mind in
particular i think this is it i'm glad
you distinguish between russian leaders
and russian people because for for
russian people it has become much more
historical but i definitely feel that
for putin and that relatively small
number of people surrounding him it is
still very very current
and look like all memories it becomes
mythologized over time
um i mean it's clear we had recently the
30th anniversary of the collapse of the
soviet union and if one looks at how
people like putin have so say metabolize
that you know a lot of it is based on
this notion that well gorbachev was weak
and it was that weakness that allowed
the system to collapse it was that
weakness that allowed the west to
essentially define us and so forth and
that may well play into his
beliefs about how he must demonstrate
strength now
and you know if one thinks of of the
experience of these people i mean these
were
these were all members of the system
they were all a communist party in many
cases kgb insiders it's not just that
they'd had their childhood and
educational experiences in the soviet
system but they'd had their sort of
early career ones
they thought they were made they thought
they knew the way the sort of their
futures were going to go and it was
pretty glorious and then this whole
system collapsed and you know you had
the recent putin saying that uh
in the very early 90s before he had got
his job you know he was looking thinking
about
basically just driving a taxi well this
is a lieutenant colonel in the kgb
now thinking about having to drive a
taxi to to make ends meet i think for
them it really has become a very sort of
salient moment and i think the two
lessons that they've learned from that
or they feel they've learned from that
one is absolutely you need to be strong
gorbachev was weak and that's why it all
fell apart but the second thing is i
think they've gone through this very
rapid end of empire syndrome that you
know so many countries go through
britain has had to france has had to
america will soon enough
where you almost move from the what have
we lost
to and who took it from us
so i think you know again the the
memories of the end of the soviet union
have become
tinged with a certain degree of vicious
paranoia but i think again that's that's
because they they still live in that
world in a way that most russians do not
vladislav finally what can the west
learn from the collapse of the soviet
union when it comes to dealing with
russia today do you think the west is
making mistakes
well the west always makes mistakes
about russia that's of course uh given
because the west does not uh
just cannot find the proper median to to
deal with russia it's either overly
sympathetic to the point of
sentimentality there's a you know strand
of memoirs and literature about heroic
russian people that suffer under that
ungodly you know bloody regime you know
be it stalin or putin and there there's
another brand of literature of like
alfons de christine oh it's asia you
know a european european uh veneer on on
asian uh essentially oriental sense of
people you know from kipling to
christine to i don't know maybe maybe
water drinker i haven't read the book
but i felt it from the reviews there's
some kind of strand of that i think the
the truth is that people uh people uh of
russia like any people from the time of
thucydides they can rally around the
leader they can turn against the leader
it really depends on many circumstances
but i think russians
when there's a challenge they tend to
rally around the leader however
however they
may
dislike the leader that happened on the
stalin
and that uh may be happening under putin
despite the fact that you know putin of
course um you know uh in to to at a
great extent instigated the current
crisis the russians believe that there's
a whole europe coming against them
currently this is not this is the matter
of course of propaganda creating this
image but at the same time it resonates
deeply with the russian national
experience in the past and on napoleon
hitler it's all well known so the west
has to be really really careful always
you know
cries about sanctions and how much poor
russians would suffer as a result of the
sections i don't think they have any
effect on the russians
except for like telling them okay we
heard this before let's let's let's uh
tighten up the belt and prepare for for
you know for for this road it doesn't
turn them against putin at least i don't
sense it you know even my relatives you
know with all my argue constantly about
politics because they're not so
pro-liberal and exposed to the west as i
am
you know they say you know let them come
we'll meet them so there's some kind of
irrational nationalism around this
so the west has to be careful not to
wake the beast
mark and vladislav thank you for joining
me
and that's it for this week once again
we're delighted that canaccord genuity
wealth management is sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes can accord will provide
the expertise you need to build your
wealth with confidence you can visit can
do wealth dot com to find out more
and if you've enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode thanks for watching and
do join us again next week
[Music]
you